virginia's new attorney general praising
governor glenn younkin for hitting the
ground running the newly minted
republican wasted no time launching an
investigation into the loudoun county
school board and named five new members
to the parole board as well here to talk
about it is the host of sunday night in
america former congressman trey gowdy
one thing that's interesting here is
you have somebody who ran not a typical
politician right he runs in virginia he
wins he surprised the democrats and then
he's following through on what he
campaigned on and the democrats seem a
little stunned by that is this a model
that other
new candidates could follow in 2022
i sure hope so dana and by the way
congratulations to you and bill on a
one-year anniversary i'm not surprised
two of the nicest people in the world um
have a successful show i i certainly
hope so i mean imagine the novelty
of running kind of a low drama you're
not talking about
you know john f kennedy jr coming back
to run with a reinstated president trump
i mean you're actually talking about
things people care about and then when
you win overwhelmingly frankly in a
state to fight and one by ten points
then you actually do what you said
you're going to do and it's not just
governor younk and i mean is winston
sears and it's the attorney general i
mean
imagine the novelty of doing what you
said you would do
during the campaign
is yunkan the guy you know sometimes you
see this big push one way or the other
is yunkan the guy who can step in the
middle of these progressive policies and
reverse them
i think he can because i i think what's
going on bill is i mean there's always
been a debate in this country about the
scope and role of government and i think
what people have seen over the last year
these that are kind of experimenting
maybe with big government
you won't secure the border you can't
get us out of a war without exposing our
troops and droning a car full of kids
you want to divide school children into
racist and victims how about just do the
things that you're supposed to do crime
border national security so i think he
is the right messenger to say look
there are things the federal government
ought to do there are things to state
all to do and then there are things
parents ought to do like you know
chiefly be responsible for the health of
their own children
later today president biden is going to
give a speech and attack take questions
from the press on his one year
in office and one of the things that you
found today from charles lane in the
washington post is this column that said
the legacy of biden's first year is a
stronger gop
do you think that that sounds right
after the tumultuous year that was 2020
now are the republicans going into this
year in the midterm in a much more
cohesive unit
i do agree with mr lane i mean if you
look at the numbers from a year ago
right after the attack on the capitol
right after you lost two republican
georgia senate seats i mean the generic
ballot had the democrats at what almost
50 percent and they've lost
nine points in a year i mean i look
republicans could not do that to them
they have done that to themselves and i
think they did it to themselves by
letting the far left i mean imagine dane
imagine a serious person talking about
closing federal prisons i mean just
imagine who in your life that you take
seriously thinks dylann roof who killed
nine black christians ought to be out of
prison someday but but when that's what
the left is talking about yeah it is no
wonder to me that people are kind of
giving republicans another look the
question is will republicans blow it
will they blow it by fighting among
themselves will they blow it by talking
about things no one cares about glenn
younkin i don't think was talking about
the vote count in arizona i think he was
talking about parents and curriculum and
public safety and things people actually
care about
remember he also is going to get rid of
the grocery tax there in virginia too um
in that piece by charles lane
what he makes clear trey and big picture
now here
is that the democratic party has to be
quote brutally honest with itself if it
looks deep into the numbers from that
gallup poll
but then he concludes by saying
essentially you can't cut to the middle
if the party won't go with you and you
know where the democratic party is today
do you believe that's a party that's
willing to shift back to a more
center-left traditional governing
pattern
i think the democrats have exactly the
same problem the publicans had
about eight years ago which is the path
to fame is disagreeing with your own
party i mean that's what made certain
republicans famous they disagreed with
their own party and so you have these
aspiring superstars on the left who
look going to the middle's not going to
get them famous it's not going to boost
their social media or their fundraising
only when you disagree with your own
team do you become a martyr and a rich
one and a famous one so i think they're
in for the same growing pains the
republicans had about about this time uh
10 years ago
great to see you trey thank you so much
yeah thanks for being here y'all too
you're a nice guy too sir thank you all
thanks thank you bye hi winner brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe
right now